lo studio del passato la passione che ci
spinge a scavare a guardare i documenti
è una passione che è dettata in realtà a
scoprire il nostro futuro
c'è una bellissima immagine biblica in
cui il tempo è rappresentato e il futuro
e alle spalle mentre il passato e
davanti
ecco di questa storia di guardare il
passato per riscoprire il futuro è
quello di cui vi voglio parlare oggi una
storia che a torino iniziata 200 anni fa
con grande lungimiranza e che sta
portando oggi ad avere una delle
operazioni culturali più importanti in
italia
abbiamo riaperto il museo egizio il
primo aprile e in due mesi abbiamo fatto
più di 300.000 visitatori cose mai viste
per un museo di archeologia nel nostro
territorio e la storia inizia nel 1824
quando un giovane del monferrato carlo
vidua scrive al re carlo felice
dicendogli che la collezione egizia
doveva essere comprata perché solo se
torino avesse avuto la collezione egizia
l'italia e bratt è bene lo dice il 1819
con l'italia ancora tutta da fare perché
come sappiamo l'unificazione del 61
l'italia sarebbe stata grande perché
avrebbe avuto la prima collezione di
antichità romane in roma la prima
collezione di antichità rinascimentali
in firenze e la prima collezione egizia
in torino
l'antichità quindi che deve segnare
l'importanza del paese
e l'idea di progredire in un grande
progetto culturale ma vi è una seconda
data che vorrei chiedere di ricordare
1894 arriva a torino ernesto
schiapparelli il direttore più grande
che quell istituto abbia mai avuto e
pure essendo chiamato la direzione del
museo più grande al mondo decide di
andare a scavare perché si rende conto
che il museo si deve a crescere e si
rende conto che quel museo deve
diventare una cosa unica
ebbene noi studiando e andando a ritroso
studiando le carte studiando i 30
nove metri lineari di archivio le 14.000
lastre fotografiche
siamo partiti da lì per riaprire per
fare un progetto che ci porti al futuro
e se può partire il primo video vi
vorrei far vedere cosa questo studio che
frutti ha portato per la prima volta
riusciamo a riportare il nostro pubblico
a quel 15 febbraio del 1906 quando si
aprì un varco e si scoprì un pozzo
funerario profondo 9 metri poi dei
gradoni nice schiapparelli separati da
un muro dopo questo muro viene un altro
corridoio di nuovo separato di un muro e
quello che si apre davanti fu questo
questa è una foto storica di scappa
rally resa tridimensionale e assieme a
lui possiamo fare questo viaggio e
tornare a quel 15 febbraio quando lui
ebbe a dire una volta aperta con la
porta le mummie potevano tornare a
vivere dopo 3.500 anni di silenzio e
tutti quegli oggetti questi 550 oggetti
che adesso vediamo in maniera
tridimensionale semplicemente studiando
e mettendo assieme delle foto storiche
sono tutte a torino l'unico museo oltre
al museo egizio del cairo dove come
tutti sapete vi è la tomba di
tutankhamon che contiene una tomba in
tanta
e prima anche brooke e date ve lo dico
io questa tormentata e stata portata
grazie a una grande fortuna le regole
del partouche dicevano che tutti gli
oggetti unici dovevano rimanere in
egitto ma nel 1905 era stata scoperta la
tomba di julia e tuia e quindi
schiapparelli c a convincere le autorità
che questa bellissima processione di
persone che andavano al libro che
portavano oggetti al nilo dal nilo poi
potevano essere portate al cairo dal
cairo genova e adesso essere custodite
al museo egizio essere custodite un
patrimonio un patrimonio che l'italia
l'onore e l'onere di custodire di
valorizzare si parla molto spesso di
cultura italiana all'estero bene uno dei
più grandi musei italiani ci collochiamo
sicuramente fra i primi cinque un museo
che non è dedicato a la cultura
materiale italiana ma la cultura
materiale egizia il secondo museo al
mondo e questo patrimonio ma custodito
ci dobbiamo rendere consapevoli che noi
dobbiamo capirne l'identità l'identità
culturale identità culturale che in
primis appartiene all'egitto e l'italia
che al centro del mediterraneo si deve
far ponte fra noi e il nord africa e il
museo egizio questo ho cominciato a
farlo i testi di sala non sono solo in
italiano in inglese ma solo anche in
arabo e questo ha provocato quasi una
reazione virale all'interno di torino
per cui i nord africani vengono in museo
portano le loro famiglie e si sentono
parte di questa cultura che a loro
appartiene non solo noi ci vogliamo far
carico di questa importante missione che
abbiamo anche andando in egitto e
portando le informazioni del secondo
museo più importante proveniente da
quella terra pubblicando finalmente in
arabo e tutti i miei curatori a partire
da questo lunedì rinunceranno alla loro
pausa pranzo per fare dei corsi di arabo
perché voglio che saremo anche in grado
a livello orale di presentare questa
cultura al paese di appartenenza un
punto un'identità culturale che però ci
deve unire perché l'egitto profondamente
influenzato il nostro paese lo fa da
duemila anni
e continua a farlo e questo si può fare
solo entrando in dialogo un dialogo che
il museo vuole fare con il proprio
pubblico con la propria città con la
nazione in cui è inserito in contesto
internazionale portando il museo fuori
dal museo attività che stiamo già
svolgendo
io sono andato all ospedale regina
margherita a portare il museo ai bambini
malati che al museo non possono venire
anziché essere andato alla casa
circondariale di oristano dove in
umanisti il progetto i detenuti
partecipano agli scavi di monte prama e
hanno parlato con noi di archeometria di
archeologia e di nuove tecniche per lo
studio del materiale ho detto più volte
il secondo museo al mondo in realtà
quando a me viene detto questo io
correggo subito tutti e dico siamo la
seconda collezione al mondo è la sfida
maggiore che adesso io ho davanti e
rendere questo museo il secondo museo al
mondo ed è una cosa ben diversa non è
solo una questione semantica di
significato la collezione è un dato di
fatto il patrimonio di cui parlavo prima
il patrimonio che abbiamo
il museo è invece fatta dalle donne e
degli uomini che vi lavorano dalle donne
degli uomini che per passione con
profonda negazione fanno ricerca
lavorano sette giorni su sette si
dedicano allo studio di questa
collezione per farla conoscere dentro e
fuori dai confini nazionali e vorrei
farvi vedere un secondo video che
attesta quello che da molti è stato
definito un miracolo e da un miracolo
grazie a chi vi ha lavorato perché in
poco meno di un anno si è riusciti a
creare quello che sembrava impossibile
spostare la collezione 5.500 pezzi
vedete le dimensioni alcuni sarcofagi
che vediamo quello di gesù ti mesti
5.000 kg che deve essere spostato mentre
il cantiere in atto
e mentre 200 maestranze del cantiere
stanno lavorando il team work e lavorare
assieme
essendo spinti dalla passione non avendo
paura di far fatica e avendo solo
l'amore per questa profonda collezione
che doveva essere protetta e che doveva
essere
asportata cercando al contempo di
coordinare il lavoro di tutti qui state
vedendo tutta la meravigliosa tomba di
kha intatta che dovuta essere stata
spostata per essere portata al primo
piano ripeto mentre il cantiere era in
atto a volte dovendoci inventare anche
delle tecniche completamente innovative
per mettere in sicurezza il patrimonio e
permettere che questo fosse valorizzato
al meglio credete
qualcomm e sono stati impacchettati
sarcofagi prima di essere trasportati e
vedete il momento in cui il papiro dica
lungo più di 14 metri è stato staccato
dal muro aperto dalla sua cornice e poi
ci siamo inventati questa specie di
ruota che ha dovuto avvolgere per
permettere di che non fosse danneggiato
poi è stato svolto e c'era un team di
restauratori che era attento che ogni
fibra fosse al proprio posto
un team e non c'era un'atmosfera
bellissima e museo dove in ogni luogo
c'era un restauratore che con il suo
team di giovani studenti metteva in
sicurezza i reperti e al contempo mentre
faceva questo si studiava di analizzava
facevamo indagine x6 facevamo tac per
capire cos'era la nostra collezione
studiare e capire è il terzo valore che
deve essere aggiunto dopo quello della
passione della negazione senza lo studio
un museo muore studiando e invece museo
a nuovi contenuti da trasmettere e un
museo vivo che può attrarre delle
persone a sempre nuovi contenuti da
trasmettere
vedete però le condizioni in cui si è
lavorato mentre in una sala gli
ingegneri architetti e andavano avanti
nell'altra cercavamo un pian piano di
posizionare tutti noi
reperti di modo che fossero qui che
ognuno ha fatto la sua parte della
signora delle pulizie a chi trasportava
i restauratori ai curatori al direttore
tutti in maniera assolutamente uguale
perché all'interno del museo quello che
conta davvero è il timore teamwork che
ci spinge tutti a lavorare nel profondo
amore degli oggetti che abbiamo la
fortuna di custodire e la cosa più bella
è stato il miracolo il miracolo è
avvenuto il primo aprile riaprendo il
museo ma vi posso dire il miracolo sta
avvenendo quotidianamente come ho detto
avere 300 mila visitatori in in due mesi
è una cosa davvero per noi mai sperata e
se questo è stato il primo passo non è
certo il punto di arrivo ma è il punto
di partenza
come ho detto voglio riportare il museo
egizio ad essere un centro di ricerca un
centro di dialogo
la ricerca è al primo punto voglio che
giovani studiosi italiani e stranieri e
finalmente mi sta venendo la richiesta
in italia si parla molto spesso della
fuga dei cervelli
io non mi piace parlare di fuga di
cervelli ma di circolazione dei cervelli
però quando si parla di circolazione
deve essere a doppio senso e l'italia
deve essere in grado di nuovo di
attrarre nuove energie
il museo egizio lo sta facendo ci
arrivano richieste di fellowship non
solo dall'egitto che ci riempiono
d'onore dall'europa e addirittura
dall'africa e di cui è una cosa che
vogliamo molto implementare perché nella
diversità nel dialogo sapremo creare un
museo più bello di quello che abbiamo e
soprattutto il museo egizio è tornato a
riscoprire le sue profonde radici senza
il passato senza le proprie radici non
c'è il futuro le nostre radici ci
portano in egitto ci portano in quei
luoghi in cui schiapparelli volle andare
nel 1894 vuole andare con i suoi giovani
collaboratori
molti dei quali sconosciuti e sarà
nostro compito renderli conosciuti al
grande pubblico e pubblicare le loro
magnifiche imprese e il grande passo è
stato il primo maggio tornare a scavare
tornare nella terra da cui questi
magnifici reperti provengono e solo in
questa in questo dialogo
stiamo sviluppando si potrà poi
sviluppare quello che in termini moderni
si chiama diplomazia culturale di fronte
alla cultura di fronte alla bellezza non
esistono paesi non esistono confini al
museo egizio si riesce ad avere
contemporaneamente l'ambasciatore
dell'iran e l'ambasciatore degli stati
uniti
questa cultura parla tutti in lei
riconosciamo le radici di cui siamo noi
e partendo da lei studiandola facendo
ricerca potremmo forse dare una risposta
al nostro futuro
un grandissimo studioso barry camp in un
magnifico libro che vi consiglio di
leggere egitto anatomia della civiltà
dice che per quanto concerne le grandi
domande esistenziali
noi siamo ancora l'età del bronzo quindi
le risposte che danno gli antichi egizi
ci possono essere utili per capire il
nostro futuro